foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar setting
the precedent for artificial
intelligence and full laboratory
automation
I am Morgan Sterling of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by copen Diagnostics to learn more
please visit copenusa.com
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits after the webinar we
do encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type in to the ask a
question box and click sentence
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
this is a replay of our live
presentation given in June of 2022 but
we will have a live q a session with our
speakers after the podcast broadcast
concludes
I'd now like to welcome our speakers
first we have Dr Caitlin Murphy who is a
clinical lab director for h l lab
medicine
we have Dr kyleen sheer who is the
National Science director of
microbiology and donor testing at Quest
Diagnostics and leads the company's
microbiology best practice team
we also have Dr Susan sharp who is the
scientific director of copen Diagnostics
we will now begin the broadcast
I'm very pleased to
announce our Fair speaker Dr Caitlin
Murphy Dr Murphy started at hnl in
December of 2019 as the scientist
scientific director of microbiology at
the same time Watch Lab arrives so that
was a nice gift
um uh subsequently she has taken on the
role as the overall clinical lab
director for hnl lab medicine and
clinical interests include expanding the
laboratory's role in clinical decision
support and quality improvement projects
such as standardization and reduced
turnaround time so I'm going to talk a
little bit about our experience with
automation I'll introduce you to our lab
a little bit to see how it kind of
compares to yours and if it's uh
um if you can make kind of the same
assumptions about how it might work in
your laboratory talk about some of our
key points and the decision to implement
automation a little bit on the
improvements we've seen with the WASP
lab and then I'll dive into some of the
studies that will be featured in posters
tomorrow on the calibri one of the newer
uh pieces of equipment with the co-pad
automation line
so as mentioned we're located in
Allentown Pennsylvania that's about an
hour hour and a half north of
Philadelphia for those who don't know
um not a tourist Mecca but it is the
third largest city in Pennsylvania we
have a large Health Network as our
primary owner that's based in Lehigh
Valley but they also have five hospitals
north of the Lehigh Valley so they serve
also a very rural population as well we
also have another hospital that we serve
down near Philadelphia that's outside of
our Network we have about over 1100
employees throughout again all of our
acute care Labs our core lab our Patient
Service Centers
as I talk about the automation Georgia
our manager couldn't be here tonight
she's joining the conference virtually
but because when I came wasp was already
on its way so a lot of this work to get
this approved and a lot of the
dedication to showing the lab the value
of this to make this investment as
thanks to Georgia
I'm sorry microbiology department is
staffed 24 7. so we do read urine
cultures and blood cultures on all
shifts not just positive bottles but we
try and work up and set up ast and all
shifts as well and so that's one of the
big drivers of having automation added
to our Laboratory
so some of the general reasons we wanted
automation if you're going to look at
automation obviously you're probably
going to do your due diligence and look
at everything that's out there we wanted
to have the quality results so hopefully
I'm not we're not in a unique situation
where someone's up and says well I got
some staff warriors growing on this
plate but not on this plate what do you
want me to do where you have to go back
look at things replace things look at
the Gram stain so really that
traceability from beginning to end was
something that we were looking at we
wanted to provide actual results again
as I'll talk about it a little bit but
it was a chance to change some of our
workflows make sure we weren't
overworking things and kind of really
change a culture shift in our laboratory
with this introduction decrease
turnaround times again that's something
that's really important to us as a
central lab it's also important to be
able to get our results out quicker
because it takes our samples longer to
get there
and we want to stick to our Central
laboratory model again there's a lot of
arguments about centralizing in
decentralizing in pros and cons to both
but we feel pretty strongly about this
model
um we also have kind of a strategic
vision for the lab as well as for our
hospital system so this was when we
added the lines we built it with the
idea of growth
um in the future so additional Hospital
Systems from our Network and additional
Labs that we would like to hopefully
manage and then of course everyone is
dealing with a limited labor market and
so to be able to reduce some of the
employee time spent plating cultures and
even reading cultures as we'll talk
about as we go through is extremely
important
excuse me so when it comes to copen in
particular we felt that the technology
was Superior what was available today
what we could purchase was better than
what was maybe promised for the future
we wanted to be able to integrate with
our other vendor platform so we have a
fairly diverse lab but we do use a lot
of equipment from one other vendor that
would integrate really well one of the
things that was huge for us was the
flexible inoculum so prior to the WASP
we did use the the privy Isola to Plate
our urine cultures and that was an
instrument that could only plate 10
microliters we felt like it really
contributed to overworking urine
cultures and so we really wanted this
flexible inoculum so with the WASP when
we put on urine culture that's a clean
void it'll plate it with a one micro
liter Loop when we played the next one
that's a straight catheter it'll go to a
10 microliter Loop it also has the
option for a 30 microliter loop as well
for some culture types
phenomatrix was extremely important as
well so this will sort out our cultures
it sorts out our growth our no growth
for our urines it'll separate out our
contaminated even we have two different
contamination codes and it'll sort those
out for us as well and then we'll talk a
lot about the calibri as we go through
um but the ability to add that at the
same time was very important to us we
did take our technologists input so they
went around to some of the labs and on
some of the site visits to kind of get
what they thought because it is a big
change we have had people who we have
lost because they didn't necessarily
like that again with the last two years
and everything going on you can't
certainly pinpoint one thing but there
was a lot of changes that came with this
and then we did actually ask the lab for
a boat as well with what they had seen
and what they learned what they would
prefer in terms of automation
um so are the improvements we've seen so
first the specimens are plater plated
quicker upon receipt into the laboratory
so I know a lot of improvements
especially with micro that can be
difficult to measure this is one we
could specifically measure so when we
looked um prior to the WASP lab over a
six-month period from the receipt to our
micro setup time so the time somebody
should have actually gone under the hood
and played in it it was close to an hour
which is um quite high but we do
consider urine cultures to be kind of
the lowest priority so at the same time
it kind of makes sense when we went to
post wasp lab I received to micro setup
time and that micro setup time is
actually sent from the WASP to our Las
so we know it's the time it really went
on not the time somebody scanned it to
say they plated it and then maybe got
distracted and that dropped down to 19
minutes same thing from the setup time
to the final result was at 29.4 hours
for our urine cultures and post wasp
when we looked at the six months post
wasp it was down to 25 hours
we schedule this times for screening and
reading based on the specimen receipt
patterns so we first got the wasp
everyone was sitting there like oh three
hearing cultures are coming off better
wait so we actually scheduled so that
they're not sitting there and screening
and reading at the same time we looked
at when specimens arrive when they're
plated when they should be coming off at
18 hours and now we have a sign
screening and reading times to kind of
reduce that wasted time of going to get
one plate that's positive at a time
and then we were able to shorten on the
first read and the overall turnaround
times with that uninterrupted incubation
so we did our validations instead of
reading you know 20 hours or 24 hours we
have all of our first reads at 18 hours
and there is a an ability to take that
lower but that's what we felt
comfortable with at that time and it's
probably something we'll reevaluate as
we continue
so looking at urine cultures in terms of
our overall turnaround times again for
no growth
um the manual time to final report was
24 a little over 24 hours when we looked
at the first couple of months after
implementation that went on to 21 hours
and then when we looked at it one year
it was down to 18 hours and so we've had
a really significant reduction for no
growth we saw a similar pattern for our
Positive Growth cultures and this is all
Commerce so it's even contamination
things that maybe just go out as yeast
call for further work up so that's why
it's still pretty low but again we were
able to reduce those times really well
and we also have it so that on first
shift you know if you read a urine
culture with the vitec is what we use
for our AST it goes into Iraq and it's
looked at 10 hours later so we can send
out the susceptibility results quicker
as well
um so some of the other kind of harder
to measure improvements is it expanded
the opportunity for our off-shift
technologists to learn to work up other
culture types so we do urines
it's hard to get people on second and
third shift everybody knows that they
get a little burnt down I'm reading the
same thing every day I'm getting bored
and so with the addition of this the
cultures are coming off all the time one
of the things we introduced is that
anybody could send out a no growth
culture so get used to looking at wounds
and other culture types as they're
coming off so that people can see that
we utilize the WASP lab images for
culture review and education so somebody
calls about a contaminated culture I can
go in and put in our container ID and
look at a picture and give them a little
bit more information talk to them and
see if they really need it worked up or
what we should do we also take subsets
of person we send them out to the whole
Lab and say what would you do what would
you report this out is what would you
work it up it's all Anonymous and then
we kind of provide education of you know
50 said this but we think this is how it
should have been worked up and again one
of the huge things we really wanted to
do was limit overworking of contaminated
cultures people do it with their hearts
in the right place but it leads to a lot
of waste a lot of um
turnaround times that go a lot longer
than they need to and a lot of confusion
I think
um again we'll talk about the calibri
um with some of the studies that were
done that will be presented but it takes
the burden off of spotting
um maldi toss Off the Bench
technologists
um so we can load the plates make our
um what we call our pick points for
those who are unfamiliar
um they come right off the WASP lab we
can take them put them onto the calibri
and the calibri does the spotting puts
the Matrix over it and all we have to do
is make the the QC spot and load it onto
the instrument
we've actually added four hospitals as
well as additional non-culture based
testing for micro we don't do the bulk
of the covid testing but that's
obviously the biggest one that's been
added because we do a lot of the the
rapid turnaround time
requiring covid tests for discharges and
things like that and again with the
quality improvements that traceability
being able to go back look at a plate we
like to do the Zero Hour image so as the
plate goes in we take a picture so that
if there's any concern about
contamination and we can go back and
look at that so again I think the
quality improvements while hard to um
quantitate have been really um
really impactful with this Edition
so for the calibri again this is um kind
of a newer although I think we'll hear
about some other newer things as well
um addition to the suite of instruments
that you can purchase for the wasp and
the WASP lab line
um and so this automates the picking of
colonies from moldy Toff and for AST
preparation the maldi plate spotting and
the Matrix overlay for both the BMR you
and the Brooker Mass Spec was FDA
cleared in December of 2021 and then the
McFarland AST has been submitted to the
FDA for the vitec in February of 2022.
the caliber will also make the Purity
plate when it makes the AST suspension
as well
so for some of the studies so this was a
study with hnl and with Kaiser
Permanente in Portland so Kaiser
Permanente in Portland supports three
hospitals as well as 35 clinics and has
about 25 micro FTE and does 161
000 cultures a year
so we combined our data looking at how
the calibri performed for multi-top
spotting
um so you can see overall we had 87 gram
positive organisms concordance of ID
where an ID was obtained by both manual
spotting and the cleavery was 100 we
didn't have any discordant
identification we did have two
um organisms that gave new no ID when
the calibri spot was done a staff
humaniticus and the gamella the staff
humaliticus was repeated and it was
identified by the clebre the second time
it was spotted the gomelo was non-viable
so we weren't able to repeat that we had
155 gram negative organisms all but one
of them even ID by both methods both
manual and by the cleaver spotting so
overall again concordance was a hundred
percent we had one that didn't give an
ID it was a klebsiella pneumonia that
was extremely mucoid when we re um
spotted it on the calibri it did work
so this is a a paper or excuse me a
poster out of Kaiser Permanente in Chino
Hills so a much larger laboratory
supporting 17 hospitals over 200 clinics
and doing over a million cultures per
year they did a similar study looking at
the overall
accuracy and concordance between the
maldi spotting done by the cleavery and
the spotting done manually by train
techs so overall the accuracy was 99.1
percent so they had two discrepant
results that they saw or manual spotting
gave an identification of streptococcus
and the calibri gave an identification
of Proteus on Investigation they think
that most likely what happened is that
the incorrect plate was tested
for a second one they had a cryutella by
manual that was identified as an herb
actor but
really there's no known cause again
what's great about to me about the WASP
lab is you can go back if you see some
sort of discrepancy and look at what the
plate looks like on the instrument as as
well if you don't have it anymore
something that happens
overall 10 of this of the 228 isolates
that were spotted by the maldi or by the
cleavery from malditov gave no ID and
then for all of these as you can see on
the bottom a majority of them being
gram-positive organisms repeat testing
wasn't performed
um and then finally another poster
um from Dr Bryant from Kaiser Permanente
in Portland looked at the AST portion of
the calibri so it looked at a total of
um 1 673 drug bug combinations
um with 106 organisms that were tested
they had 11 discrepitive results for
categorical
interpretation so the overall
categorical agreement was 99.34 percent
they had
nine of them were minor errors and two
major errors with no very major errors
so again the the percent of overall
agreement was extremely high and then
they had overall essential agreement
again of 99.7 percent so again very high
agreement what we would look for when
comparing one method to another
so overall
um happy to I think at the end we're
going to take any questions or talk
about our experience at the cleavery but
the maldi performance of the cleaver you
get a high level of concordance between
manual spotting and automated spotting
and again with the studies you kind of I
guess probably tend to favor our better
spotters I don't really ask you know our
not so great spotters if they want to
participate in something like that so I
think in the real world you'd actually
probably get
um even higher
at a higher identification overall with
the calibri perhaps than with various
spotters in your laboratory
um the cleaver is an accurate method as
well for the preparation of these spots
so very few discrepants we're seeing
um and for some of them there was some
explanation that was available for that
uh the AST the calibri automated
performance is equivalent to manual
methods and used for susceptibility
testing on the vitek too so overall it's
another piece of equipment that frees up
Technologies Technologies time for
valuable tasks it standardizes the
Maldive plate spotting and AST
preparation so again all done by an
instrument not a lot of variability from
person to person and then it gives you
that full traceability as well
so our next speaker
is Dr Keelan Shear
um
Dr Shear is the national scientific
director of microbiology and donor
testing a Quest Diagnostics based in
Chantilly Virginia and the chair of
Quest Diagnostics microbiology best
practice team so thank you very much Dr
shear and
no to you all right thank you
I will be speaking to you about our
experience with high capacity
microbiology automation
so my talk will go over the expectations
we have for automation
two approaches that we had with two
different installations in our
institution some challenges some results
some future opportunities so before I
get started I want to say that this was
not Quest first
Venture into laboratory automation
looking into automation everything from
stainers to Plate streakers we had had a
variety of different instruments
sometimes just at a few locations
sometimes a lot of instruments at a lot
of locations so we had quite a bit of
experience in terms of the pitfalls with
automation the benefits of Automation
and we actually even had a prior
experience with the total lab automation
system so we were pretty Concrete in
what we were looking for in terms of
expectations
so we knew with our size and our
complexity we really needed a platform
that could be tailored to fit our needs
that could fit our volumes our
configurations our testing protocols it
needed to be able to be something that
could work for our sites and the
variations even within those sites we're
also looking for flexibility things
evolve over time and we needed a system
that could evolve with us as our
protocols changed and updated as our
volumes changed something that we could
adapt without having to you know scrap
the whole system and start over again
we had learned from our past automation
experiences how important reliability
was because we became very reliant on
the technology especially from a labor
perspective so we needed that automation
to be consistent or we were in trouble
we of course were looking for a
reduction in labor as we have the
previous speaker already discussed and
as all of you know medical technologist
labor is becoming harder and harder to
find and I'll talk a little bit more
about what we achieved in terms of Labor
savings we of course are always looking
for reduction in turnaround time as
Caitlyn mentioned we're a Reference
Laboratory we're already losing time and
getting the sample to us so we want to
make up as much of that time as we can
while still providing quality lab
results and of course we're looking for
Quality improvements trying to reduce
some of those errors that occur because
people are people and they're not
perfect
so our two approaches we our first
installation was actually at a fully
operational laboratory so that was
exciting and had its own challenges
which I'll speak more about in a minute
the second installation we have the
unique opportunity that we were building
out a brand new Clinical Laboratory all
disciplines not just microbiology but
that gave us the chance to build
essentially our Dream microbiology lab
with Automation in mind
now in both cases we took the same
validation process so we started just
with water runs literally running tubes
of water through and making sure you
know it didn't get stuck along the way
did the doors work did the belts work
just very much a mechanical validation
then we moved in
um and that was after our Factory
acceptance testing then we moved into
seated uh specimens using atcc strange
just making sure we recovered growth
looking at you know mixed cultures could
we find you know a staph aureus that was
buried in an E coli that type of thing
then we actually did our clinical
validation using de-identified Remnant
samples tested in pairs you know with
our automated method and our manual
method
and then finally we loaded it up with as
much volume as possible and saw at which
point we basically backed up the system
so in the
as I described this was already a fully
operational Lab at this particular
location been operating at that location
for about eight years so the challenge
was how do you stand up a new system
while also keeping the day-to-day work
going and we
remodeling the building was not on the
table so we knew that the system we
implemented had to fit within the space
within the lab
as it existed already
we really didn't have a lot of extra
space or swing space so this became a
dance you know move a piece here you
re-verify that okay put in this piece
okay move a piece here re-verify that
put in that piece and so that led to
multiple phases of installation because
of that lack of Swing space so that did
drag out the validation timeline because
we had to break it into so many parts to
keep our functional laboratory
functional
so uh one of my favorite pieces of the
system is the collaborative workstation
and so we use this for our non-standard
specimen types we have done a lot of
client education trying to get them to
move to a liquid-based medium
clients can be very stubborn and opposed
to change
and some of them have just not got with
the program so of course we still get
non-e swabs and we still get sputa and
currently we're getting stools in
caribbear transport medium so we use the
collaborative station for those specimen
types that can't go onto the WASP blow
automated disorders and down that line
and this has a nice five axis robot if
you haven't seen it before but what I
really like is when you read the sample
it knows what plates you need to Plate
it puts the barcode labels on it brings
them out and it lifts the lid I don't
know if any of you have ever had this
experience but I have where we're going
to work something up and attack forgot
to set the McConkey or whatever other
plate and you're going how did you
forget the McConkey plate but this
instrument prevents that from happening
I also really don't want to think about
how many times plates are mislabeled by
people in a Clinical Laboratory we don't
know I would be terrified to know
probably you would too but you don't
have to worry about that because this is
labeling it and it's only opening that
patient's plates that are being plated
right at that moment and then it takes
those it can feed it down the line or if
it's something that's incubated offline
it can put it into the canisters for you
to take say for example your anaerobes
that's why I love this robot is quality
you know error prevention is really high
with this
so now let's move on to our new
construction so again there were very
minimal design constraints it was what
what do you want the microbiology lab to
look like and while we had work going on
at another location there was no patient
testing being performed in this building
at that time so we didn't have to do
that you know instrument Shuffle uh as
we were installing so that really
simplified things we were able to design
the optimal workflow as we saw it and
install everything in two phases because
we weren't having to work around you
know med techs with plates and
incubators Etc
so now I'm going to talk about some of
the improvements we saw broadly in
categories of laboratory management
front-end processing incubation culture
reading and then culture workup and
Reporting
so as far as laboratory management we
already had a number of reports that we
could use with our own proprietary
laboratory information system but this
has a couple of nice features one of
which is you can set it up to send
automatic emails to like our corporate
email addresses so key people wake up
every morning and they have a system
report you know how's the system doing
what's the workload how many plates came
in how many have been read you know so
it has all of these metrics and data
that in past you know you'd have to go
look at the bench and you'd guesstimate
like okay they've got three stacks
they've got five Stacks you know so now
we have quantifiable data about the
system about the workload about when the
plates were ready to read versus when
they were actually bred so as you're
looking at your Staffing models
um you know somebody leaves you get the
opportunity to hire someone else okay
where's where should we slot them in so
that those plates are being read as soon
as they're ready to optimize turnaround
time
it has tracking on components you know
is there a particular belt that you know
is giving an issue that would show up on
these reports and then there's this uh
real-time system dashboard so we have a
very large installation here and
um at this particular location and all
of the alarms sound the same
so without this dashboard you could be
standing going okay where is that coming
from so this dashboard allows you to see
exactly which line needs your attention
so you can go quickly resolve that issue
all right so as far as the front end
processing we do have the WASP flow
systems so for our liquid specimens our
e-swabs our urine and gray tops we can
just dump them into the flow it does all
of the Sorting you know it's sending
them to the WASP platers when it's done
it actually prepares them to go Bank
them for storage and so we're really not
handling I mean literally we take them
and just dump them in uh it doesn't look
very classy but it's really quick
so it also eliminates those barcode
labeling errors that I was talking about
with the collaborative instrument right
you don't have that human interaction
you've got an instrument that's
consistently labeling things
it's consistently inoculating the plates
the same way streaking the plates wet
the same way so that you get nice
isolated colonies
immediately goes into the incubator with
that little small
any of you have the continuous
monitoring temperature systems on the
big incubators you know what happens the
moment you open that door starts
alarming and annoying everyone because
the temperature is just all over the
place with this little door it just goes
in no fluctuations
and I already talked about the specimen
storage it gets them ready to go so you
can just take it to your storage
location
so the incubation I think is maybe one
of the more underappreciated elements of
this system so each plate basically has
its own heated air curtain around it so
all of these plates in addition to not
having that big door open and close each
are being basically individually
incubated so if you think about it you
know that's like making like little tiny
mini muffins versus you know making a
big cake and the center is not quite
done but the edge is already starting to
burn so this way everything's getting
incubated uniformly and we have found
that this really enhances the growth
it's allowed us to validate shorter
incubation times with equivalent results
again getting results into Physicians
hands faster than we could with the
manual incubation we also take Time Zero
uh pictures as well as subsequent images
um so that's very helpful to see what
was on the plate to start with what's on
the plate later can also be helpful if
there's like an overgrowth you've got a
you know a proteus decided to take over
the plate you're trying to see what was
there before the Proteus expanded
um so that can be very helpful for us as
well uh looking backwards
all right so our images are taken at
predefined times that we have validated
to be optimal for our workflow and we
use the phenomatrix artificial
intelligence system so basically this
system
um I'm going to speak more about it in a
minute but it has been modeled based on
our work our pattern validated against
our manual methods to essentially screen
our place for us so just like your text
they sit down the bench what's the first
thing they usually do pause snake pause
snake right they sort them out work up
their nags work up their pauses separate
maybe they're mixed growths are
somewhere in the middle that's what this
system is doing for you
so it gets everything sorted out so that
when your Tech sets down to work on it
they know okay I'm working on the no
gross I'm working on the mixed I'm
working on the positives
again I've already talked about we can
pre-review uh images this is really good
for difficult cultures overgrowth and
this technology actually enables remote
reading which that's you know many
people's stream retirement job right I'm
going to sit in my fuzzy slippers and
replays from home
all right so I talked a little bit about
our reduced reduction and turnaround
time so we have been able to validate a
shorter incubation time for some of our
cultures what's really cool about the no
gross is once the technologist has
confirmed their no growth so
everything's still in the Technology's
hands those plates go to the trash the
technologist never touches the negative
plates and so that's a lot of time
savings when you think about it they're
only handling the positives
the phenomatrix tag really you know up
their handling because everything's kind
of pre-grouped for them and this helps
training with new techs because you can
start them on okay and and Caitlyn
shared you know okay everybody can learn
how to do no gross it doesn't matter
which culture we we can teach you how to
do that and then you can show them
because you've got images of interesting
things but also sometimes it's just that
repetition right seeing it over and over
and over again you can some of your
prior plates to just get them familiar
with how things should look as you're
training them
so we also have the calibri instruments
I'm not going to spend too much time on
these because Caitlyn did a great job
reviewing these
um and focus a little bit more on the
phenomatrix so this is example of our
strep culture it does take this wasp lab
system takes pictures with two different
lightings so you can really see that
nice molasses there's the eye here so
you can actually look at the patient
demographics it does have them grouped
if you don't agree with how it called
you can use the drop down arrow and say
you know no this I don't agree I mean in
this case you would not say this is no
growth but let's say it was oh that was
just some junk captured on the platelet
that's no growth I can change it right
there
you can set up essentially your
phenomatrix to be you know if you will
custom folders so these initials over
here some of them might mean something
to you some might not those are
basically taken from our Sops so they're
meaningful to our text they know that
these are different workups that need to
be done according to our standard Sops
so they know when they're setting down
what they should be looking at what
should be in the gis versus an NGA
Etc
you can set up you can customize how
many plates you view at a time so if
you're reviewing no growth urine
cultures you can set it up so you're
reading a lot more plates going through
the text can zoom in at any time if
there's anything they see that they
don't you know they're not sure about
they can zoom right in and look at that
and you do have to confirm the number of
plates before you release it out so that
you can't go oops I didn't look at that
bottom row that you are confirming
you're reading all of those plates
so again with the phenomatrix tag it
once you have confirmed that yes you
want to do ID and susceptibility on the
calibri the system will say here's the
colonies it suggests for ID on multi-top
here's the colonies it suggests for
susceptibility testing but you can move
these if for some reason you don't like
what I picked you can move these around
and send that to the calibri so when you
get the plates on the calibri it's going
to prepare your maldi spot it's going to
prepare your suspension for
susceptibility testing with the colonies
that the technologists picked
so challenges
one of the biggest challenges is this is
a new way of doing microbiology you know
gone are the days of going to the
incubator pulling out your stack of
plates physically sorting through them
that's a very tactile clue as to your
workload now it's really digital your
your queue is digital what how many are
in this folder how many are in that
folder and so it's learning to use those
digital dashboards those digital metrics
to judge your workflow as opposed to
what's physically in your hands so
that's a little bit of a mindset shift
for all of us
information system and like every
interface I've ever been a part of it
took longer than we thought
um that just seems to be how it goes so
it is interfaceable there's a lot you
can do with it but when you're
considering a validation just break into
it that there's always something with an
interface
and then preventative maintenance and
instrument operation
microbiology is kind of like the last
place to go automated right don't
generally have a lot of high complexity
equipment our staff aren't as used to a
lot of equipment and so they had to
learn how to deal with us Automation and
the type of Maintenance so it's wiping
down tracks and cleaning sensors that's
not something that micro staff have
historically had to do a lot of and so
it's a little bit of a different
maintenance it's not hard it's just
something different and so learning how
to work differently in the lab
so um some future opportunities we are
always looking at what else can we put
on the system you know what other media
what other culture types that we can
build onto this system what other
phenomatrix tag algorithms can we
develop with Copan to automate more of
that screening initial step of our
cultures we are always looking for ways
to improve our interface with our Lis in
a perfect world we would do everything
in the web app application on copin and
not really even have to get into the Lis
anymore and be able to just send
everything out and have it flow
seamlessly through so that's
trying to achieve through various phases
of course looking at you know additional
hardware and we provide feedback to
co-panel we we like this but we don't
like this piece about the carousel could
you make it you know could you make this
the number of samples on this match this
so to provide that user feedback of
things that we've found you know they
work they work fine but you know what
can we do to make it even better we're
always looking at you know what's the
next module the pipetting module for
stool specimens the new radian module
that I believe Dr Sharp's going to talk
about so looking at what other
enhancements what other things we can
put on this system to automate even more
so this is just kind of a summary
schematic of the old way of doing micro
if you will where we start with
specimens maybe they get manually
streaked maybe they get put on a wasp
they get loaded into the incubator then
they've got to be offloaded after
they've incubated you're going to screen
them then you're going to read them then
you're gonna go upset you know set up an
I.T or ID rather and susceptibility
when you look at the WASP lab automation
there we are
you dump specimens in
and at the end you have plates going to
the line for the cleavery workup or if
they're Negative they just go straight
in the trash and you've never touched
them again so it's kind of amazing to
think about how many Hands-On steps you
have saved
so one piece I forgot to mention from a
labor savings perspective is
in addition to looking at how do we save
labor how do we reduce the amount of
technologist time and use more
non-licensed time you know more lab
assistance so you don't need a
technologist to empty the trash with the
negatives
before our technologists handle the
negatives right because they're
screening through them in this you've
now transferred that work to a group
that is lower cost and quite frankly
easier to find and easier to train than
our medical technologist
so it's not just a reduction in labor
but also a shift of the labor to a
different work group that might be more
feasible for us to maintain especially
with our staffing shortages that we're
seeing today
so in summary it is a pretty long
validation process obviously each
laboratory needs to Define within their
own you know system what that
requirements look like if you're having
to build this up in an operational lab
it's going to take longer than if you
are privileged with a new site and you
can put it in from scratch
it is very difficult and slow to change
client Behavior to the systems that are
compatible with the automation so if
that's something that you would need to
do plan plenty of time for that as well
our technologists actually were really
quick to accept this technology you of
course always have your handful of
naysayers but by and large they were
super excited about this and really
willing to work on this and I do think
part of that is that we had had some
other automation types so it wasn't
quite as foreign to them as it might
have been if we had been completely
manual
and we did see that labor savings we did
see the reduction both in over all labor
needed and the type of Labor and so for
us that didn't nobody had to be laid off
that was not our problem our problem was
can we take more volume with the same
staff or in some cases you know if
someone left it we not need to fill
their position largely quite frankly
it's more of the more volume with the
same staff being able to accommodate as
quite frankly some of you know the other
facilities other hospitals are looking
to Outsource more of their work this
allows us to handle that with the
Staffing we have
excellent reliability with the system
and if you recall from the beginning of
my talk that was very important to us so
you might have a single component go
down but you don't have the whole system
down so you just you know reroute around
that until you get that one particular
Lane that belt fixed and then you're
good to go
and then we've definitely had an
improvement in just kind of an
overarching view of laboratory
management our access to those metrics
that data so we can see what's going on
in the laboratory real time both from an
instrument performance standpoint but
also a workload standpoint
so I will stop there and we will be
taking questions at the end thank you
most of you know Dr Sharp she she
currently serves as a member of the
board of clinical and laboratory
standards Institute member of the
subcommittee for antimicrobial
susceptibility testing for clsi governor
for the American Academy of microbiology
and his past member of the board of
scientific counselors for the office of
infectious diseases at the CDC
she has lectured both nationally and
internationally and has published
numerous scientific articles I'm sure
some of you are read and also book
chapters in the field of clinical
microbiology so sue sharp thank you very
much and over to you and I'm going to
close out
of the the talk tonight and introduce
you to Copans radian and radian is
copan's automated disc diffusion testing
for the clinical microbiology Laboratory
and
I'm going to introduce you to radian by
going through this the study Hub on the
slide here for you now and this is a
study that was done with the caliber
you've heard a lot about calibri from
kyleen and she did a really good job
explaining how that all works as did
Caitlyn for us as well so these
investigators use the Colibri together
with the radian the automated
distribution testing for susceptibility
and this uh study was published in the
journal clinical microbiology last year
in August and it was done during done in
Dr chakali's laboratory in Switzerland
so the aims of the study two aims they
wanted to assess the categorical
agreement between the vitec 2 system is
which is what they compared it to and
compared the Colibri radian under their
routine laboratory conditions so this
was done under their real routine
laboratory conditions to see how
everything worked and how the two
systems compared the outcome measures
was not just the accuracy of the new
system but they also wanted to look at
throughput as well as the effects on
workflow
so they did a rather large study they
did uh 675 non-duplicate clinical
isolate strains these were strains that
were in the laboratory in 2020 when they
performed the study they did 249
introbacter alleys um that came through
the laboratory naturally but they also
ceded
um the inter-bacter alleys with an
additional 43 banked organisms that were
carbon panamace producing enterobacter
alleys again they wanted to
um
task the system a little bit to see how
it would work with these enzyme
producing organisms so there were seven
New Delhi Metallo beta lactamase
producers three kpcs 16 oxa 48 like and
17 Oxo 181 like organisms that were
included in the inter-bacter alleys
group they did almost 200 pseudomonas
originosa over a hundred staphylococcus
aureus and an additional 78 coagulase
negative staphylococci and then a
smattering of intercoxi as well in the
study to give a total of 718 strains
that were included in this study
comparing these methods
how they started they used the calibri
in the study the calibri prepared the
disc diffusion suspensions either from
technologists selected colonies on the
plate or by using the automated
selection feature of the phenomatrix tag
which will automatically select the
colonies for you they did some time
measurements and found that they were
able to pair prepare about 10 organism
suspensions in about 20 minutes
next the WASP these suspensions were
wasp and the WASP prepared the diffusion
plates from The Colony suspension
from here the plates were shuttled off
to the radiant inline Carousel now the
radiant inline Carousel contains up to
50 different antibiotic cartridges so
lots of different choices that you can
have for
um the organisms in your laboratory for
what drugs you want to place and you can
place
um different selection protocols from
placing one disc to placing eight discs
then anywhere in between on your 100
millimeter plates and then then the the
um
seated plates with the discs on them
were shuttled off into the WASP lab for
incubation and imaging
they also then use the radian expert
system software to automatically
interpret the Zone diameters and this
can be done either using ucast
guidelines as they did in this study but
also software is available for
interpreting clsi guidelines as well
when you look at the plates when you
look at them on the screen the images on
the plates they will show a green halo
around the organisms that are
susceptible a yellow if it's
intermediate and red would be resistant
so the radian result as I said were
compared to the vitec 2 results if the
results agreed then there was no further
testing that was done however if the
results between the two systems did not
agree then they underwent discordant
adjudication
so um on those isolates majority of them
the testing was repeated using a broth
micro dilution system with the
sensitizer however if they were able to
see that the discordant results were due
to this colonies being visible in the
inner Zone here of hemolysis due to a
heter-resistant populations then they
retees repeated the tested using the
testing using the e-test because they
wanted to see if those same colonies
would show up on the inner Zone with the
e-test as well
now they characterized all their
discordant results as either major
errors this is if the radian and um
would call the or the vitec would call
the drug bug combination resistant but
the standard uh test the reference test
which was the broth micro dilution or
the e-test called it susceptible and
they called a result of very major error
if it was susceptible by susceptible by
the radian or by the vitec but was
called resistant by the broth micro
dilution or the e-test system so taking
these all together
there was a total overall categorical
agreement in the study with all
organisms at 99.1 percent
they did have a chart I wanted to share
with you about comparing these two
systems between first with the the
calibri couple to the radiant is a fully
automated system it's very easy to
change out the antibiotics if a new
antibody comes along you have 50 50
cartridge slots that you can stick one
of those into
um it has a great flexibility if you're
um uh
uh drugs change from therapeutic
Therapeutics came to you and said we're
going to switch out this third
generation cephalosporin for a different
third generation silphasporin you can
easily do that with this diffusion
testing
um it's also very cost Effectiveness as
we know that the discs themselves are
relatively inexpensive
um they are they said that the uh this
diffusion with the radian is obviously
very reliable for detecting those
hetero-resistant populations which are
difficult to detect sometimes with broth
micro dilution mic testing and also it's
very easy to see tests failures if you
had an inoculum that happened to be
mixed we know we can detect those mixed
inoculums very easily using a Kirby
bowel or a disk diffusion system it was
more accurate for the detection of some
of the newer resistance mechanisms
is also applicable to which I'm glad the
authors pointed this out so I remind
reminds me to tell you that it is
applicable to more fastidious organisms
as well because the system and the
software does work quite well with blood
Mueller hit and auger as well
the only drawback with the calibri
coupled to the rating is is a drawback
that we see with just diffusion in
general that you don't actually generate
an mic result
comparing that to the vitec 2 system the
authors point out that it's a
semi-automated method it's less flexible
it's not very easy to change the the
drugs in these cards very rapidly it can
be more expensive because you do have to
buy the susceptibility cards in panels
it had a lower sensitivity for the
detection of these hetero-resistant
sub-populations
also keep in mind different from our
distribution test and you do need Purity
check plates when you're using a broth
micro dilution system or an mic system
so again that's more consumable costs
and more labor time for the laboratory
as well the vitec 2 did have some
problems detecting some of the carbop
enemies patterns and the range of the
dilutions in the cards can also be quite
narrow again so if U cast or clsi would
increase a break point or decrease a
break point again might be difficult to
utilize those cards if they don't go
high enough or low enough in the mic
range but it does provide a very good
approximation of what the mic of the
organism actually is
so uh in conclusion they they conclude
what we all know
um that the workload requirements for
manual disc diffusion testing really has
hindered the uptake or the continued use
of disk diffusion in the laboratory
many of us were using this diffusion
years and years ago and we were very
excited and very happy to go with this
semi-automated mic testing instruments
some of it's not all of us some of us
are still doing distributes of testing
which is great
um but again because it was more
expensive but it saved us a lot of Labor
time as well so there was a lot of
people switching away from the manual
disk diffusion testing but these authors
conclude that the calibri coupled with
the radian address all these constraints
and they do it with an accuracy that is
equal to or better than that other by
Tech 2. they said that they were able to
process eighty percent of the routine
susceptibility Tusk using the
equilibrium the Radian that the
calibrium the radian is also going to be
able to help them implement the rapid
automated dish diffusion testing
directly from blood cultures which we
know ucast has guidelines for and clsi
now have guidelines for as well
the emergence of new antimicrobial
resistance mechanisms can be more easily
detected with this diffusion
Technologies compared with commercial
mic devices and again as was alluded to
by our earlier speakers AST testing
reading can also be done at earlier
times this is something that with the
Brady and the calibri with the
continuous incubation
um with the the software and the Imaging
that we have we really think we're going
to be able to shorten up that 24-hour
period for reading or routine
susceptibility testings as well
so if I can just have a few more minutes
of your time we'd like to share with you
uh how this all works and how this all
comes together to make a really great
automated system for just diffusion
testing so ladies and gentlemen wasp
blob calibri and Radian
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
perfect well I'll be there for you guys
thank you bye-bye
alrighty thank you so much speakers for
your informative presentations we will
now start the live q a portion of this
webinar if you do have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located at the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
can calabri make AST suspensions for
other than the vitek II instrument
Dr Murphy do you mind answering that one
for me
sure
um So currently the calibrious FDA
approved to make the suspensions for the
vitek II
um however it can make suspensions for
other systems um so depending on your
timeline and if you're interested in
doing it kind of an in-house validation
that's a possibility but given that
capability Copan is working on clearance
for other systems and I think Dr Sharp
would be able to comment on maybe what
to see expect to see next
yeah thank you we um Copan is um
planning to go ahead with FDA clearance
for microscan preparations as well so
that's in the works
awesome
and how long did it complete validation
take and how many employees did you have
focused on this validation do you have
any tips on the efficient validation
process
I think that's maybe for Dr Sharer
okay so my answer is going to be a lot
of it depends
um in the first installation we had it
took a lot longer because we kept having
to like move a piece and then revalidate
some equipment and then move a piece and
then revalidate something else so that
really expanded the timeline somewhat
artificially it was also our first
experience so in the second experience
it was much faster but also we didn't we
weren't an operational Lab at that point
so we weren't trying to do it alongside
patient testing
um and we actually had a dedicated
corporate team that was working on that
validation so it wasn't really
reflective of I think what most people's
validations would take
um overall we estimate a full system so
multiple lines but going into kind of
one full system would take approximately
a month
um but again that depends on what kind
of resources you can throw at it and
then in terms of tips for an efficient
validation process I don't know if this
is an efficiency but if you can get your
early adopters your people your texts
that are super excited about this system
on board with helping I think that's
going to one build you know knowledge on
the product it's going to build
enthusiasm for it and they're more
likely to jump in and put in that effort
and get it going so hopefully that will
build efficiency but just getting those
early adopters engaged as soon as
possible we found that to be very
helpful
um in speaking the timeline along and
then the final thing I will say is it's
probably going to take longer than you
budget because I feel like every
validation on Earth takes longer than
you budget
and um Dr Murphy would you like to add
anything about your experiences with how
long it took you for a complete
validation and how you have an efficient
process
sure um and I honestly don't remember
the exact time frame um our biggest uh
kind of hurdles were on the I.T side so
there's certainly areas of our it group
that are used to working with
instrumentation and automation but
they're not usually the people who are
also familiar with micro so I think
there was a little bit that tended to be
where most of our challenges were
um as well as just the testing of when I
hit this button on the WASP lab web app
it goes to this
stacker where I want it so just figuring
out those workflows I think for
efficiency
what I would recommend and I think what
was recommended to us was to make any
changes you can make
that'll come with automation
um in advance so for our wound cultures
we were doing the ADL L disease somebody
was reading those so we had two people
on the bench splitting the cultures
you're not gonna be able to do it
necessarily that way
um with automation so we did away with
that in advance
um some new codes that we added we could
have probably added before we had
started the system just thinking about
how do we want to kind of batch report
certain things so I think that's one of
the ways to make it efficient is to
start changing the parts of the process
you can change without Automation in
advance so that it makes the transition
a little bit easier
thank you
awesome
um next question approximately what
percentage of total specimen culture
volume at your facility do you have on
automation plus pm and what specimen
types are you currently using with the
PM tag and what types are you planning
on using tag for in the future
sure I can take that so in thinking
about bacterial culture volume so not
AFB not mycology all of that just
looking at our bacterial cultures about
80 percent
um is on automation we don't have our
blood cultures on there for obvious
reasons
um so by far the vast majority again one
of our limiting factors is client
behavior I'm getting clients to switch
to um transport media that is compatible
we of course use the collaborative robot
to overcome a lot of that
and then we primarily use uh the PM tag
with our urine cultures so think about E
coli the primary pathogen and neuron
cultures so we have that validated
um looking at our aerobic cultures again
looking at primary pathogens like staph
aureus
um we were actually just talking about
kind of what's next we would love to do
in our caucus because it's prevalent
both in urine cultures and aerobic
cultures so we kind of get a two for one
on that so I think that's where we'd
like to go next uh with the phenomatrix
tag
great and what other algorithms might
Laboratories be able to enjoy with Copan
in the future Dr Sharp do you mind
answering that yeah no uh happy to um in
addition to what Dr Shearer already
talked about she she mentioned um in her
presentation the baby hemolysis program
so there's an algorithm that will detect
beta hemolysis which can be very helpful
for sorting out throat cultures when
you're looking for uh beta hemolytic
streptococci it will sort out those
cultures that have hemolysis away from
those that do not so presented positives
away from your negatives Dr Sher also
talked about staph aureus there's a
program that can be used
primarily for any source that are really
usable for wounds that can sort out
those cultures that have staph aureus in
them on routine media of a way for those
that do not look like they have any
staph aureus associated with them
as she said there are urine we have a
lot of different urine phenomatrix
artificial intelligent algorithms that
can detect growth no growth
insignificant growth which is depending
on how the laboratory identifies that it
could be less than 10 colonies also
mixed growth again depending on how the
laboratory defines that which could be
three or more different types of
colonies
um and uh can bend those and folder
those into different folders away from
your significant cultures
it can also detect E coli whether you're
using a chromogenic media or a
non-chromogenic media and also do your
Colony counts for your urines at less
than 10 10 to 50 50 to 100 or greater
than 100 colonies
in addition to those we have basic
growth and no growth algorithms that can
be used for basically any source and we
also have several different chromogenic
detection modules which can be used with
chromogenic media for screening for
different pathogens like MRSA bre group
a strap Group B strap cre or esbls Etc
can be used basically with any
manufacturer's chromogenic media
and then we also have user-defined rules
where the phenomatrix can bring in some
patient demographic information we have
one customer that is using this with
their urines uh so that even if you see
a mixed urine culture they're using a
biplate with chromogenic media on one
side and CNA agar blood auger on the
other side so even if the program sees
that there's a a mix or a contaminated
urine culture
um it will also let the laboratory know
that there are a few colonies on the CNA
side so there's a grant Positive Growth
there this is a woman who's 27 years old
so she is a child bearing age so this
culture would be sent over to a bin to
investigate to make sure there's no
Group B strep on that culture we have
some new algorithms we're looking at
briefly for stool cultures also for
screening for candida RS on the New
chromogenic Media that's being developed
and also a new auger that's being
developed a chromogenicographer
screening for streptococcus A and C and
G so lots to look forward to in the
future as well
great thanks for sharing next question
is the radiant Foley FDA approved
yeah I'll take that one too the um the
radiant it depends on how you use it
um is my uh how I'm going to basically
describe it
um as we talked about the the calibri is
FDA approved now for making suspensions
for the Vite Tech 2 and we're um
pursuing getting those done for
microscan as well so if you're using the
calibri to make your suspensions for the
radian
um then we that would have to go through
an FDA process however if you're if
you're not using the calibri you're
making your own suspensions that you're
putting on the WASP to streak out your
plates and then you you look at the the
radiant results afterwards all of these
do have the radian results all have to
be looked at by a technologist there's
no Auto release function of these so you
look at Technologies would have to look
at all the Zone diameters if they
disagree I think as I said in the
presentation if they disagree with the
um the measurement it's very easy to
adjust the measurements around around
there to what the technologist
would might feel is more appropriate
than what the radian measured during the
study that I presented they found that
they had to do this less than 10 percent
of the time but again the tech does have
to look at all these and approve them
before they can be released so an FDA
approval FDA clearance would not be
necessary in that case
great
next question how did you manage to find
Personnel to take care of the electro
mechanical issues that such automation
requires different qualified lab
Personnel or other
uh Dr Shearer did you want to take that
I I can certainly take that
um I can't recall if I went over this in
my presentation but this is definitely a
shift for us when you think about
medical laboratory Sciences historically
those that loved equipment went into
chemistry they didn't come to micro so
you didn't always have the most
mechanically inclined medical lab
scientists in microbiology and obviously
with this automation there's a lot more
moving Parts I talked about the
maintenance is a lot of wiping down and
whatnot so there's a little bit of a
shift there but any major mechanical
issues we we call for service we're not
going to mess with any major issues
fortunately we've really not had a lot
the uptime has been really really good
so we're not really looking for a
qualified you know people or people with
you know mechanical engineering
abilities to do this if it reaches that
level where we're going to rely on
copamp for that support
awesome and any idea how calibri
spotting works for more fastidious
organisms Dr Murphy
yeah so
um we've we've tested a variety of
organisms with our verification and we
don't see anything that comes up pretty
much in our daily practice where we have
any
issues with spotting any particular
types of organisms we do still maintain
kind of best practice or do our best to
do that so certain festivities things if
there's a concern that we want to screen
it offline first before we put it on the
maldi or the calibri as well as if it's
something like a urine with with vein
growth we'll typically just pull it off
to do a Gram stain so it certainly isn't
something that we've seen
to come up on our day-to-day operations
we are do have some data from the study
we showed that we had done the abstract
on and are trying to add some more
fastidious isolates on that to kind of
drill down a little further in general I
think you saw from the the video Dr
Sharp showed at the end of her
presentation it's a very minimal spot
that the caligri makes compared to what
we're used to attack you know kind of
coloring in the whole circle
um so it doesn't really need a lot of
biomass but certainly can't make it
appear where it where it isn't so I
think for really really tiny colonies
you might have some issues but otherwise
we haven't encountered any
um
any issues with spawning festivities
organisms using the cleavery
great and based on your experiences what
would be your suggestion to Laboratories
considering purchasing automation but
are also facing moving to a new space
soon should they wait for the new space
or Implement in the current laboratory
and move to the new space when it is
ready
so we have zero experience with moving a
Covan wasp lab
um so I can't really speak to uh how
that process would go but I think it
would probably be a better use of your
time to really plan out that new space
and plan the automation around that and
what needs to happen for that space
um rather than installing it and then
having to move it and then you know
revalidate it again
um so that having no experience having
moved it that's just kind of my
perspective knowing what's involved with
the space planning and the installation
and validation of one of these systems
yeah I'll just add to that that we have
had helped customers with with moving
their wasp blob and it can be done
great well looks like that is a wrap on
our questions thank you so much Dr
Murphy Dr shear and Dr Sharp thank you
again for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots in our sponsor copin
diagnostics for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we do encourage you
to share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time thank you so much for
your time and goodbye